mikey likes it became a famous
advertising catchphrase for life cereal
it also inspired a different mikey who
went into the ice cream business mikey
co owns his own store here in new york
city vlad duties shows why mikey found
business success and a way back to his
community after a run-in with the law
what's up vlad good morning nate good to
see you my brother lifelong new yorker
mikey he opened his first shop seven
years ago and he has since expanded to
two other locations get this he counts
jay-z and hillary clinton among his fans
but despite his famous following mikey
told me he strives to do more than just
make good ice cream he hopes his story
will inspire others
stroll through new york city's east
village with mikey cole
he's so much more than just your typical
ice cream man he's an all-american
success he's an entrepreneur that's the
backbone of america just watching people
walk by you hey mikey what's up and you
know everybody by name people who live
in the building above you people walking
down the street i'm a product of my
environment but in order to make a
change for the better you got to become
the environment
i've had people come in here they're
upset they have a scoop of high school
they leave happy that lets us know we're
doing our job the job for mikey began
nearly a decade ago after spending five
months in rikers island for possession
of marijuana with intent to distribute
before
you
were selling ice cream
you were selling drugs
how did that
fork in the road present itself to you
my aunt leaving
gave me the
the road to say this is your calling i
found my my purpose in life
and when you surround yourself with
others that keep that in you
i'm not going down another path his late
aunt and the discovery of her ice cream
recipe while cleaning out her closet
served as his inspiration i'm on my
tippy toes like trying to grab stuff and
this cookbook fellow like hit me in the
head from the floor and i opened it it
was ratatouille and vanilla ice cream
when i saw like eggplant zucchini
peppers i was like oh no
you know mikey found meaning in
replicating her recipe every time i make
ice cream
i sort of hear her a little bit talking
to me on messages that she was trying to
instill in me my aunt told me if you
make something with love and the person
who sees it with love
they're going to keep going on the day
with that love and energy the business
born in the kitchen of his manhattan
apartment became a local hit you did
have people turning up at your door once
word got around in the neighborhood oh
man burntly lived on the seventh floor
in my building
every day
burley would spend twenty dollars on ice
cream you got yourself a beer cart the
cops pulled up on me and they were like
buddy you out here selling beer and i'm
like ever said no they look at the car
and they're like
no beer here but we wanna scoop with
this ice cream though
[Music]
today with pop culture inspired flavors
like foxy brown ice ice mikey and
truffle shuffle mikey likes it appeals
to neighborhood veterans and newcomers
it's like when you look at the
neighborhood like things have changed
other business open other business close
but there's certain things that just
stay the same you're on this corner
where you grew up basically but you go
into the world to the world it looks
like i eat all the ice cream but i'm not
eating on the ice cream
we're here because the community wants
us here
when it comes to thanksgiving we're out
here with tables and we're feeding
people on thursdays we're giving out
plates all from a business that's 200
square feet in here and you never know
where that message goes
mikey's mission now transcends ice cream
there's many mikeys in every
neighborhood we got to find them
and grab them when they're young it's
ice cream it's life but it's bigger than
all of that so here is a coffee
bacon and syrup waffle and the
inspiration for this is cbs mornings yes
sir ice cream is breakfast is a great
pick-me-up all right
i know he said it's cbs mornings
but this just says to me vlad
[Music]
back in 2012 mikey met a childhood
friend of jay-z who challenged him to
make a flavor for the famous rapper the
result dusse de leche a take on ducey de
leche using jay-z's do say cognac daisy
liked the flavor so much he put it on
the menu at his 40-40 sports club it's
no longer sold there but you can still
order pints of mikey's nationwide i love
everything about mike right right in the
middle of the piece tony and i both said
at the same time where is this again
where is it again the lower east side
he's got another place that he opened up
uptown um and we're standing on the
corner you saw on the piece people are
coming one guy comes over to him he's
like hey i remember him when he was a
preemie and i said are you kidding he's
like no he was a premature baby i knew
his mom they live in the same building
same neighborhood
expanding even more he's trying but
right now he's really happy where he is
but it sounds like he's he's making
grandma's ice cream but he's not going
to make grandma's gratitude oh he's on
it's ice cream i like the recipe book
hitting him in the head and he's like
onions peppers
that was great vlad thank you very much
mikey's awesome i want to go yeah you
got to go i want to meet mike ice cream
is self-care and self-love get some
today
you're not going to get in trouble
selling ice cream either mikey nothing's
going to happen all good things